[Music]
Carhartt the company has been a part of
streetwear culture as long as streetwear
has been around Drake Rihanna and Obama
are only a few of the big names who have
dawned the brand it's worn by folks that
might be wearing Carhartt 2 tech jobs or
might be wearing Carhartt as they trade
crypto on The Daily but Carhartt didn't
chase after this consumer and its
popularity in fashion has little to do
with the company's strategy in fact the
Workwear brand strategy has been rather
consistent across 134 years even while
its competition changed course
this is the economics of Carhartt
when Carhartt was founded in 1889 the
American Workforce looked pretty
different than today's at the turn of
the century an estimated 38 percent
worked on farms and 31 worked in mining
manufacturing and construction when a
traveling salesman named Hamilton
Carhartt asked railroad workers how
their uniforms could be improved he used
his findings to create the first
Carhartt product a pair of overalls
these are some of our early styles of
overalls from the earliest years of the
company over time Carhartt expanded we
start making work pants which at the
time were called waste overalls we
started introducing jackets and codes
the overalls chore coat and the double
front pant laid the groundwork for
Carhartt's brand and they've remained
relatively unchanged we always have
those core products we always have that
denim we always have that duck it's
always going to be something that you're
going to be able to get from us having
that Foundation is what allows us to do
some of the experimentation we do as the
workforce evolved and the number of
railroad workers and Farmers dwindled
experimentation was key and Carhartt's
consumers gave the brand an idea today
there is no article of clothing that
better represents Carhartt than what's
known internally as the a18 watch hat
aka the beanie Google searches for
Carhartt and its beanie have increased
over recent years at 1999 the beanies
are priced as an entry point for
first-time customers and are a top
selling item for the brand each year
car's popularity right now is best
described as this thirst for
authenticity this thirst for genuine
clothing the way fashion works right now
it's it's not necessarily that one trend
is super dominant Carhartt is finding
purchase with a lot of different waves
of trend right now and it's not the
first time the family-owned company
exploded into the mainstream
[Music]
in the 80s and 90s Dickies and Carhartt
were picked up by skateboarders and
famous rappers as streetwear that had a
trickle-down effect once rappers are
wearing it then other people wanted it
as well Dickies leaned into the
attention on its Instagram page you'll
find photos of farmers and Woodworkers
but you'll also see a lot of
skateboarders whereas Carhartt almost
exclusively shows people working in its
clothes
Dickies also expanded its product lines
adding more options for skateboarders
today it has a total of 159 men's pants
and shorts and its original 874 work
pants come in 21 colors
Carhartt on the other hand sells 67
items under the men's work pants in
short section this includes items like
jeans and a single pair of sweatpants at
most it makes a pair of pants in eight
colors but many have between two to four
options while Carhartt's websites and
stories are important for the company
they're not yet the company's biggest
source of Revenue instead the brand
still relies heavily on wholesale
distribution to other retailers like
Tractor Supply Dick's Sporting Goods and
Bass Pro Shops but recently Carhartt
explored a new way to reach workers so
in 2018 we started Carhartt company gear
because there was a consumer need to
provide uniform that can be embellished
with different companies logos and names
not long after it partnered with United
Airlines providing uniforms to 28 000
workers and in 2023 Carhartt and The
Weather Channel announced a partnership
while Carhartt has presented an
unwavering Devotion to Workwear there is
a caveat back in the late 1980s when
streetwear took off a European retailer
made the company a proposal he'd take
Carhartt's merchandise and tweak it for
a European audience Carhart agreed and
in 1989 All-American concept was born
soon after it was renamed to Carhartt
work in progress as a licensee Carhartt
work in progress caters to anyone
interested in streetwear and other
apparel inspired by Workwear and in 2011
it expanded to the US
importantly Carhart work in progress
still reports to Carhartt they make
decisions together and work in progress
as revenue is a portion of Carhartts
it's been really wonderful to have the
licensee with Carhartt work in progress
and it does allow them to address a
different consumer but it's still
inspired by Workwear so that allows
Carhartt for us to really focus in on
building the most durable and versatile
Workwear for the job site versatility is
really something that our consumer has
seemed to have created kind of on their
own we start off as this Workwear
company right and we all of a sudden you
know see our stuff being used in the
outdoors camping hunting you know all
those other kinds of of uses for like a
rugged heavy duty product seeing this
inspired Carhartt to create a new
product line called super ducks in the
1930s for all these other outdoor uses
but this line didn't take off back then
people already had outdoor jackets from
Carhartt their work jackets they didn't
need another one still Carhart learn
something key its Workwear clothing was
being used for far more than just work
over the course of a few decades this
Revelation changed Workwear and the
original companies that made it in the
1970s Carhartt expanded Beyond outdoor
apparel starting with a sweatshirt we
can go how to make a t-shirt or make a
beanie or maybe play around with some
sort of contemporary Styles this mindset
defined the company over the century and
helped to grow even while many Americans
pivoted from working Outdoors to offices
there were many Workwear manufacturers
in America at a certain time and a lot
of them for a multitude of reasons have
fallen away they don't exist anymore
they've gone bankrupt they've been
subsumed by a different company and
those clothes just aren't existent
anymore work and the way people think
about clothing has changed significantly
in 134 years but Carhartt hasn't just
because someone wears something for a
utilitarian job doesn't mean they're not
thinking about how that product looks on
their body this kind of fashion consumer
and this function consumer I think they
cross over in a lot of places and you
know you might have the car heart jacket
because it looks really cool but then on
a 30 degree day you might be really
happy you have it
[Music]